hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're talking about
calculations with sign numbers what our
science numbers you might ask this
refers to numbers that are positive and
numbers that are negative you might also
ask why is learning calculations with
science numbers important for the field
of biology well it turns out it's
important for several different
scientific fields biology chemistry
physics etc and that is because there's
a lot of math in the scientific field
places in biology where you might use
calculations with science numbers
include converting between different
temperature scales by converting between
Fahrenheit and Celsius or back again and
also doing other calculations like
calculations with specific heat now
let's look at multiplication and
division of science numbers when both of
the numbers being multiplied or divided
are positive that make the answer pretty
straightforward for example we know that
two times four equals 8 and 14 / 2
equals seven this is because when you
have two positive numbers being
multiplied or divided the answer is also
positive however when you have one of
the numbers being positive and one of
the numbers being negative the answer is
negative that is three times negative 2
is negative 6 negative 8 divided by 4 is
negative 2 negative 4 times 5 is
negative 20 and 18 divided by negative 3
is negative 6 so you see in all of these
cases you have one positive number and
one negative number being multiplied or
divided and the answer is negative it
does not matter which of these numbers
is positive or negative now when both
numbers being both multiplied or both
numbers being divided are negative the
answer is positive that is negative 3
times negative 4 is a positive 12 and
negative 20 divided by negative 5 is a
positive 4 so you can remember this by
thinking that
whenever the two numbers being
multiplied or divided have the same sign
the answer will be positive it doesn't
matter if it's two positives or two
negatives the answer will be positive
whenever the numbers being multiplied or
divided have different signs then the
answer will be negative so that is
multiplication and division with science
numbers now let's look at the rules for
addition and subtraction again when both
numbers are positive it's fairly
straightforward two plus three equals
five and four minus one equals three
again we have positive numbers being
added or subtracted the answer is
positive it gives a little bit more
complicated when one of those numbers is
negative however what you can do
whenever you have a situation like this
two plus a negative four you can
actually rewrite it to be 2-4 2-4 is the
same as 2 plus and negative 4 and the
answer is negative 2 we see the same
thing here negative 5 plus a negative 4
you can rewrite this to be negative 5
minus four which equals negative 9 now
it's a little easier when the center
number is just a positive and the number
being added is a positive like negative
6 plus 1 becomes negative 5 I do want to
point out something special here and
that is that in all of these cases the
answer has the same sign as the larger
number so we look here the larger number
is positive the answer is positive the
larger number is negative the answer is
negative the larger number is negative
the answer is negative and here both
numbers are negative so of course you
have a negative answer with subtraction
you can also whenever it's minus
negative minus a negative let me see in
two of these situations you can actually
turn them into pluses so for example 6
minus a negative 2 can be written as 6
plus 2 which equals 8 and negative 7
minus a negative 3 can be rewritten as
negative 7 plus 3 which equals negative
4 again a little easier when there's
just a minus a plus in the middle
negative 5 minus 2 equals negative 7 and
again we see that same rule holds true
in addition and subtraction whatever the
sign of the largest number is the sign
of the answer will be the same here the
largest number is positive the answer is
positive here the largest number was
positive the answer is positive in both
of these cases the larger number was
negative and so the answer is negative
so that is how you do calculations with
science numbers thanks for watching and
we'll see you next time